du volley assis du tir à l'arc ou encore
un stand de formule 1 le jour un trail
la nuit avec pour unique éclairage une
lampe frontale la nouvelle édition du
raid organisé par les étudiants de
centrale supélec se voulait varie en
offre sportive pour sa nouvelle formule
objectif attirer un maximum de
participants
le but ça a été de faire un événement
qui sont accessibles à tous aussi bien
pour le niveau sportif que pour que pour
l'ambiance
donc c'est à dire cette fois c'est pour
ça que le nouveau le nouveau format a
été adopté avec des activités dont qui
sont quand même un caractère sportif
mais aussi le village de rambouillet et
c'est une course
plusieurs tracés en vallée de chevreuse
ont permis notamment aux plus courageux
de parcourir jusqu'à 110 km en deux
jours en équipe de quatre et dans une
ambiance décontractée une condition
essentielle quand le corps est ainsi
mise à rude épreuve
nous on est on est un peu des sportifs
du dimanche à né pas on n'a pas
l'habitude de courir
mais on s'en sort et on aura quelques
crampes pendant un ou deux mois mais on
va survivre
le tir à l'arc
alors je sais pas trop comment on s'est
débrouillé
je connais un chasseurs de sangliers qui
a touché deux cibles ici une chasseuse
donc c'est à 16h pour ce week-end
sportif des entreprises des étudiants
étrangers et des personnes à mobilité
réduite étaient également conviés à
relever le défi
prochaine étape pour les meilleurs
d'entre eux en avril avec cette fois ci
une course organisée en occitanie et 250
km au programme